bonsoir bienvenue en kiosque votre
magazine culturel alors au menu ce soir
une géométrie incidente c'est le titre
du livre de que Jean-Louis Poidevin
écrivain et critique d'art consacré au
sculpteur 5quantinois Nicolas San le
Plaisirois Xavier SEO est passé de
l'écriture à la réalisation au jour le
jour son premier long métrage est
maintenant disponible en DVD c'est
l'invité de kiosque et puis dans sa
chronique Nicolas Gervet nous emmène à
la découverte de la création de théâtre
de chair ceux qui boîent actuellement
joué au théâtre heridis de plaisir et le
12 mai à La Verrière voilà ce que l'on
peut découvrir dans ce nouveau numéro de
kiosque Jean-Louis Poidevin signe un
ouvrage entier consacré exclusivement à
Nicolas San sculpteur cantinois
originaire de Rodz une géométrie
incidente le titre de ce très beau livre
qui retrace les 30 ans de carrière de
l'artiste et qui permet d'en savoir
évidemment un peu plus sur la
personnalité de Nicolas Sagne des images
chier Patrick Jacques de dixmut sur un
montage de Xavier
Jalin un livre rien que sur l'œuvre de
Nicolas San 2 ans d'écoute et
d'observation pour le critique d'art
Jean-Louis Poidevin une géométrie
incidente le titre de ce livre pour
retracer le travail si particulier du
sculpteur qui modèle l'acier comme
personne auparavant effectivement il y a
une invention et il y a il y a il y a un
style il y a quelque chose quand il n'y
a aucun autre sculpteur français alors
on pourrait mais même si on regarde chez
les sculpteurs qui vont utiliser en
partie les mêmes matériau à marouvero
par exemple et cetera on va bien on va
bien voir que non les questionnements ne
sont pas les mêmes il a posé une
véritable question jusqu'où peut-on
aller dans l'équilibre dès lors que l'on
met en jeu des force incommensurable
avec cet équilibre je veux simplement
aller jusqu'au bout ce que je peux faire
aujourd'hui et demain je su pr encore
plus loin parce que il sera demain
j'aime cette idée de de se donner
pleinement dans ce qu'on
fait parce que c'est comme ça que je
conçois les choses existence parce qu'à
moment donné j'ai bien compris que je
pouvais être aussi à la limite de ma
propre vie Nicolas San travaille seul
dans son atelier C cantinois il dessine
il calcule il expérimente il monte et il
regarde lui le natif de rodise né de
parents agriculteurs reproduit sur
l'acier les sillons de son enfance
venant de la terre j'ai besoin d'avoir
ce contact direct avec la matière pour
et c'est aussi une réponse pourquoi je
fais la structure ce qui lie mon travail
depuis le début c'est la ligne alors ça
va être la ligne qui est celle qui est
tracée par
une her dans un champ et un paysage et
lorsque j'étais étudiant quand je
faisais des grands tableau noirs en fait
je je inconsciemment j'ai essayé de de
retrouver ça ce livre retrace 30 ans de
carrière un accomplissement dans la vie
d'un artiste même si rien n'est encore
fini il y a plusieurs façons de faire de
l'art quoi il y a des gens qui
travaillent de manière spontanée ou
impulsive moi je pense que une
véritablere d'art elle se passe dans le
temps dans la durée de temp et pour cela
il faut et pour faire de l'art en fait
avant tout il faut se comprendre je sais
pas ce que le le
le le temps me réserve de d'espace pour
travailler mais en tout cas chaque
minutes est consacré à
travailler Xavier bonsoir vous êtes
romancier depuis peu hauteur d'un long
métrage tiré d'un de vos romans au jour
le jour un longmétrage qui étit diffusé
en juin dernier au cinéma des des clés
sous bois et qui fait l'objet en ce
moment même d'une sortie en DVD avant
qu'on parle de ce travail que vous avez
mené un peu particulier autour de ce
long métrage je vous propose d'abord de
regarder la
bandeannonce
c'est moi meilleur ici
OK
alors voilà pour ce long métrage au jour
le jour donc qui a été diffusé en juin
dernier au cinéma des des clés sous bois
rappelez-nous un peu l'histoire de ce
courtmétrage de son longmétrage pardon
ça a démarré il y a 2 ans au lycée Sonia
de l'onet de de Villepreux c'est ça
alors en fait il y a 2 ans je
travaillais dans un lycée et j'ai voulu
faire un club vidéo et à la base je
pensais pas qu'on ferait un projet aussi
gros je pensais vraiment faire une
petite vidéo d'une vingtaine de minutes
et au final il y a eu un un très grand
gouement de la part de
de jeunes qu'on frappé à la à la porte
du club VI exctement on était 60
inscrits donc vraiment avec 60 inscrits
on a pu vraiment faire quelque chose
d'assez conséquent et comme j'ai j'avais
déjà des romans qui étaient publiés dans
le commerce il y en a un qui se passait
dans un lycée avec des jeunes et
beaucoup d'élèves ont ont beaucoup aimé
l'histoire donc du coup on se'est dit
allez partons sur ça et du coup on est
parti pendant 4 mois de tournage mais
vraiment 4 mois de tournage intensif on
filmait le le soir le le weekend parfois
les vacances c'était vraiment une très
bonne aventure quoi c'est un Paris un
peu un peu fou ouais ouis c'est c'était
vraiment super qu on faisait franchement
on faisait que que ça pendant 4 mois et
euh et et comment vous avez travaillé
justement avec ces avec tous ces élèves
alors chacun avait un poste de travail
particulier il a fallu que vous
réécriviez un petit peu le l'histoire
parce qu'il faut forcément d'un roman
arriver à aboutir à un fil exactement
d'ailleurs j'ai sorti au j jour il y a
en 2008 ou 9 et du coup j'ai réécrit
l'histoire j'ai réinventé l'histoire par
rapport au roman et ça m'a même donné
l'envie de réécrire au jour au jour le
roman qui est actuellement commce c'est
pas le même que celui qui était en 2009
et du coup on j'ai réécrit l'histoire et
après lesquipe comment s'est mis en
place C c'est vrai que ça étit compliqué
parce que forcément c'est un film
amateur ça c'est c'est c'est bien é bien
évident mais j'ai vraiment donné des des
rôles et des places dans l'équipe
technique en fonction de la motivation
et de l'implication des élèves il y a
des élèves qui d'eux même ont pris des
places se sont motivés pour pour être à
la caméra pour être pour faire le la
musique pour faire soccuper des
accessoires s'occuper de de
l'organisation générale et du coup les
élèves motivés qui étaient là qui qui
donnaient de vraiment pour pour faire
avancer le projet ils avaient
naturellement le le rôle c'est que
l'organisation n'a pas pu faire quelque
chose de de de très organisé à la base
on est parti en fait dans le projet et
en fonction de ce qui était là 4 mois
c'est quand même rapide pour arriver 4
mois c'est rapide pour arver en fait on
a fait deux mois exactement de
d'écriture avec moi et Jean-Christophe
Poulin c'est le nom qui éta écrit dans
le dans la bord d'annonce et et après 4
mois de tournage exactement et puis
après 2 mois de posttraitement alors
l'histoire de au jour le jour alors
l'histoire elle est assez compliquée à
raconter puisque il y a en gros c'est
comme on peut voir dans la boî d'annonce
j'ai fait exprès dans la boî d'annonce
de ne pas montrer l'histoire je n'aime
pas les Bones annonces qui racontent
tout l'histoire mais la bonne annonce
permet de comprendre le cadre on
comprend com on comprend un peu rugueux
quand même oui voilà mais par contre
l'histoire on ne comprend pas l'histoire
on voit le cadre on voit un petit peu
les situations et les thèmes abordés
mais on ne voit pas l'histoire moi j'ai
voulu en fait raconter l'histoire de
jeunes et montrer leur les influences et
la violence qu' peut y avoir entre eux
et comment ils peuvent s'engrainer dans
la bêtise parfois et du coup je dirais
pas plus sur l'histoire parce que j'ai
vraiment envie de laisser découvrir euh
alors découvrir en DVD comm
ça l'enchaînement je veux juste dire
effectivement que il y a un personnage
principal qui à la base nétait pas
spécialement méchant on va dire ça comme
ça puis on va voir comment les rencontre
entre il y a six personnages principaux
en tout en un qui est dominant quand
même comment ils vont vraiment euh se
c'est assez éigmatique s'influencer les
uns les autres jusqu'au un peu le coup
de théâtre on va dire final faut pas le
dire coup de Th
donc le film avait été diffusé en juin
dernier au classousbis et maintenant il
fait l'objet d'une sortie en DVD c'est
une sortie un peu particulière parce que
le DVD est vendu 13 € et il y a 6 € qui
sont reversés à votre association
expliquez-nous pourquoi comme c'est de
toute façon c'est un projet bénévole et
donc tout le monde moi y compris on
touche absolument on a absolument rien
touché sur sur le projet de jour le jour
mais on a décidé de le vendre en DVD euh
il coûte 13 € et et j'ai décidé
de que tous les bénéfices ça fait 6,24
les bénéfices iront j'ai une une
association qui s'appelle kfen studio
qui permet de réaliser des projets
culturels
dont réaliser des films ce que je fais
actuellement je j'essaie de réaliser mon
mon 2uxè longmétrage et du coup la vente
du DVD c'est pas seulement acheter un
DVD en fait pour 13 € c'est aussi
participer à la réalisation d'un projet
culturel donc de ce fameux second
longmétrage qui sera aussi tiré d'un
nouveau romans exactement ce deuxème
roman n'est pas encore sorti par contre
j'essaierai de synchroniser vous en
train vous êtes en train justement de
l'écrire voilà je suis en train de
l'écrire et je suis en train de réaliser
les films je fais les deux en ce moment
on peut vous demander l'histoire en tout
cas la thématique l'histoire pas encore
mais au moins déjà parleznous du thème
de ce second très bien je vais faire
comme au jour le jour je je n'aime pas
raconter les histoires parce que j'aime
j'aime comme moi quand je veis au cinéma
j'aime bien découvrir les films j'aime
bien découvrir être surpris êre et au
rire quand il y a une blague et
finalement quand la blague on la voit
dans la B d'annonce on la rig on en
rigole plus dans le film et donc je vais
faire pareil le deuxième film va
va va traiter en fait de la question de
la
justice a la justice institutionnelle la
justice médiatique la justice aussi
personnelle peut on faire justice
soi-même alors toutes C tous ces thèmesl
ne sont pas abordés de manière
philosophique posé dans le film avec
avec des débats entre deux personnages
ça sera bien sûr mis en scène à travers
des des des actions du suspense des
mystères et encore des énigmes
exactement j'aime beaucoup c'est
vraiment mon style j'aime beaucoup
écrire des histoires que ce soit en film
ou en roman où il y a vraiment une
aventure pleine de rebondissement de
péripéties avec un coup de théâtre final
mais pour ceux qui aiment bien se
divertir mais à la fois aussi voir une
deuxème lecture ils sortent du cinéma où
il finissent un de mes romans en se
disant tiens il y a des thèmes qui sont
pas si bêtes en fait à aborder mais qu
quand vous écrivez maintenant ce nouveau
roman qui don il est prévu de faire un
un long métrage alors forcément vous le
décrivez de façon particulière ou sû
qu'on dit cinématographique c'estàd très
visuel c'est exactement ça voilà c'est
c'est vrai que euh j'ai j'écris des
romans depuis maintenant plus de 10 ans
mais je me suis mis dans la vidéo il y a
a 3 ans à peu près et c'est vrai que
maintenant quand j'écris des romans je
pense énormément à ah tiens quand je si
j'ai un jour je peux le mettre en scène
comment je pourrais le mettre en scène
et du coup ça influence et on m'a on m'a
déjà dit plusieurs fois que j'avais un
style un que je faisais des romans
cinématographiques que quand on lisait
mes romans on avait l'impression de voir
un film en fait ah ben voilà bah c'est
parfait merci en tout cas d'êtreevenenu
sur le plateau de kiosque donc je
rappelle que votre DVD au jour le jour
est disponible on peut trouver alors il
y a le site internet aussi qui s'est
affiché sur votre site internet donc
pour savoir où on peut trouver ce DVD il
y a aussi votre adresse mail comme ça si
vous on souhaite vous écrire pour
trouver ce DVD donc à 13 € et qui permet
aussi de financer une association qui
vous permettra de réaliser ce votre
second long métrage merci beaucoup
d'être venu sur plateau de kiosk et on
va évidemment poursuivre cette émission
avec aussi une page
cinéma
et oui c'est la chique cinéfilé comme
tous les mercredis on va commencer par
vos avis de spectateurs au micro d'é
moine super très très bon film il pas
beaucoup de monde d'ailleurs mais très
très bien belle performance de Manu pa
de Mor aussi très très bien j star
plutôt ah moi j' bien aimer que c'était
bien parce que c'était rigolo c'est très
coloré c'est drôle comme tout en même
temps c'est tout ch j'ai même pleuré
c'est très mignon mais euh à conseiller
pour les familles c'est vraiment très
sympa c'est magnifique quand on aime les
chevaux et quand on aime la musique les
deux euh c'est magnifique magnifique
émouvant c'est très bien joué d Pontel
je l'ai rarement vu comme çaant je le
suis depuis pratiquement tous ces films
il est génial et nous poursuivons cette
chronique cinéfile avec le coup de cœur
d'un professionnel du 7e mars cette
semaine Bertrand Pignier des yeux d'Elsa
de saint cirlécole
le coup de cœur du cinéma Les Yeux
d'Elsa aura lieu du 22 au 28 avril c'est
un coup de cœur qui concerne également
quatre autres salles de la région à
trappe etlencour Fontenet et donc à
sainciir l'école nous participons à un
festival qui s'appelle Play It Again un
festival qui a pour but de faire vivre
les films d'hier dans les salles
d'aujourd'hui et àenscir l'école en
particulier nous organisons deux
événements liés à ce grand événement
national le premier événement aura lieu
le mercredi 22 avril à 14h il s'agit
d'un cinégûté animé autour du du de la
série de courmétrage les nouvelles
mésaventures d'Harold Lloyd Harold Lloyd
c'est un des grands génies du burlesque
américain avec Kiton et chapeline il est
un peu il est un peu oublié maintenant
mais c'est vraiment un grand monsieur
très très drôle et donc on remettra en
avant ces films le mercredi 22 avril à
14h dans le cadre d'un ciné goûté
l'autre éement c'est une cinéconférence
sur un film de John Frankenheimer un
film de 1967 noir et blanc un film qui
s'appelle seconds qui était sorti en
France sous le titre l'opération
diabolique un film tout à fait étonnant
particulièrement inventif d'une grande
grande modernité que j'aurai le plaisir
de vous présenter en cinéconférence le
mardi 28 avril à
21h c'est vraiment deux films à
redécouvrir à découvrir ou à redécouvrir
parce que seconde c'est un film très peu
connu euh des grands moments de cinéma
en perspective donc et à très bientôt au
cinéma Les Yeux d'Elsa et dans les
autres salles de la
région et puis une cinquantaine
d'étudiants de l'École des trois is
d'élancours se lance dans un projet de
réalisation d'une série de quatre
épisode de 10 minutes chacun intitulé
les insurgés de marax sur le thème du
monde de l'entreprise et de la révolte
le tournage de cette miniérie doit
démarer le 6 mai et pour se faire les
étudiants ont lancé un projet de
financement participatif sur UL ils ont
besoin de 2000 € pour financer donc leur
projet le site est ouvert jusqu'à début
mai explication avec deux protagoniste
du projet Jules Burgat il est
réalisateur et Clara Payet c'est la
Directrice de Production c'est les
employés d'une succursale qui subissent
un plan de restructuration qui vise un
licenciement donc de de la sucursale et
donc ces employés décid de prendre donc
leur délégué leur représentant du
personnel en en otage c'est un sujet qui
qui nous a touché car c'est c'est actuel
on est quatre réalisateurs un par
épisode nous avons deux showruners donc
les showruners qui ont qui sont à la
base de de la série l'idée on a une
équipe technique donc de d'une vingtaine
de personnes en image une dizaine de
d'ingénieurs son et une dizaine de
monteurs notre modordre c'est vraiment
la débrouillardise on essaie de trouver
tout ce qu'on peut chez les gens on fait
par exemple pour les décors on a fait
une grande liste avec tous les meubles
les accessoires dont on avait besoin et
on l' donne un peu à tout le monde pour
savoir ce qu'on peut récupérer et puis
ensuite on essaie d'acheter au bas prix
dans des magasins comme Emaus on a mis
en place une campagne de financement
participatif sur hulule c'est-à-dire
qu'en échange de contrepartie en rapport
avec la série des personnes nous donnent
un peu d'argent et nous on leur envoie
une sorte de petit cadeau qui représente
marax il y a un montant minimum qu'on
qu'on doit atteindre avant début mai
c'est 2000 €. et en dessous de 2000 €
c'est-à-dire qu'on perdra tous les gains
qu'on a gagné au-dessus de 2000 € ça
serait vraiment bien parce que ça nous
permettrait d'avoir des décors encore
plus plus beau et des des costumes aussi
encore plus beaux pour nos personnages
et voilà et si vous voulez soutenir ces
étudiants de 3S rendez-vous donc sur la
plateforme de financement participative
Hulul leur projet donc marax la série
est ouvert jusqu'à début mai et puis
encore une autre date cinéma retenir
celle du vendredi 17 avril une nuit du
cinéma propose à la Maison de
l'Environnement à Manil et à mot par des
élèves du lycée de Villarois de cuill en
cour sur le thème héros ou criminel une
nuit réservée au plus de 12 ans
é mettant en scène au sein du Théâtre de
chair le théâtre qui propose ceux qui
boîent Nicolas Gervet a rencontré
Grégoire cuvier il signe le texte et la
mise en scène de ce compte contemporain
sur l'histoire d'un homme devenu
amnésique après un accident qui doit
apprendre à se reconstruire le texte
s'appelle ceux qui boîent sera présenté
notamment le 12 mai à la ferme de Bel et
bas à Guille encour voici Grégoire
cuvier dans le kiosque c'est tout de
suite c'est maintenant c'est par là tu
suis non mais attends tu suis s'il te
plaît
oui ce qui boîent ça raconte l'histoire
d'un homme qu'on retrouve totalement
amnésique dans un gigantesque
carambolage sur l'autoroute à 6 il est
sans bagage sans papier
et impossible de déterminer qui il est
et d'où il vient et tout au long de la
pièce on va suivre super personnage sur
sur sa
reconstruction et puis ce personnage va
croiser c'est une sorte de récit Coral
il va croiser d'autres personnages dont
l'histoire a été brisée et c'est
l'histoire comme ça de destin cabossé
qui se
rencontre avant la création j'ai
travaillé 3 ans avec les acteurs et au
début le point de départ ça a été de
travailler sur l'altération des
perceptions de la réalité dont
l'amnésie et pour ça on a travaillé
beaucoup autour de romans plusieurs
romans d'aruki Murakami ce romanci
japonais qui a notamment écrit un
q84 la balade de l'impossible le
voyageur sans bagage de Gen à nouille un
court essai de Nancy Huston qui
s'appelle l'espèce fabulatrice qui
développe l'idée que par essence l'homme
raconte des histoires pour construire
son identité et son rapport au monde et
ça c'est une notion qui est vra au cœur
de ceux qui boitent c'est comment on se
construit ou comment est-ce qu'on se
reconstruit à travers la mise en récit
de notre
vie on travaille sur des personnages sur
des situations sur des improvisations on
passe aussi par beaucoup de longtemps de
d'expérien kinesthésique sensible qui
n'ont pas de lien direct avec la pièce
mais qui vont nourrir un petit peu d'un
point de vue sensible
l'acteur et puis on a fait beaucoup
d'impro autour de création de personnag
autour de situation sachant que nous on
a une manière de d'aborder l'impro qui
est qui est très éloignée des matchs
d'impro par exemple c'estàd que pour une
impro qui va durer entre 5 et 10 minutes
il peut y avoir jusqu'à 4 heures de
préparation on développe un travail
d'improvisation complexe voilà qui qui
est vraiment le la base
après pour moi de l'écriture en
réinvestissant également tout ce travail
d'expérimentation qui est fait avant
autour du sensible moi je j'ai commencé
à écrire la pièce je me suis mis devant
l'ordinateur pour écrire après 2 ans de
recherche et puis j'ai écrit on a
retravaillé à partir de là et pendant un
an ensuite le texte a été retravaillé
remanipulé au fil des lectures qu'on en
faisait je me suis rendu compte au fur à
mesure de mes spectacles qu'on disait
souvent que c'était très
cinématographique alors il y a pas une
recherche particulière pour moi de créer
un langage cinématographique mais c'est
vrai que c'est vraiment ma nourriture le
cinéma et notamment
euh l'approche dramaturgique
anglo-saxone donc c'est vraiment la
manière de penser l'écriture très
cinématographique très série de télé
avec des plans très courts des séquences
qui s'enchaînent avec une dynamique dans
le récit et puis l'histoire le
déroulement du récit au cœur de
l'écriture là le dispositif scénique est
très très simple ce sont cinq stelles de
verre qui selon comment elles sont
éclairées soit soit reflèteent ce qui se
passe sur scène soit joue de la
transparence du verre donc effectivement
les lumières qui sont faites par Nicolas
Faucheux le frère du scénographe qui a
conçu les stelles de ver crégoard
fauchux voilà c'est deux
collaborateurs sur l'espace
scénique les lumières ont une importance
capitale parce que selon selon la
manière dont on va éclairer le plateau
ou l'Estelle de verre les reflets vont
varier la notion de double en fait est
développé tout au long de la pièce
c'était un des éléments de langage pour
lesquel on a voulu travailler avec le
verre et puis c'est aussi cette question
d'opacité révélation comme un petit peu
le verre qui soit peut nous renvoyer à
nous-même ou laisser voir à travers lui
tu te souviens tu te souviens
pas tu te
souviens tu te souviens
pas tu te souviens pas à
bientôt les spectateurs sont très actifs
par un spectacle qui cherch vraiment à
comprendre à relier les points à tisser
leur propre histoire et c'est moi il a
une idée que j'aime bien c'est qu'au
théâtre ce qui est intéressant c'est pas
ce qu'il y a sur scène c'est ce qu'il y
a dans la tête du spectateur et je crois
qu'on on déploie un dispositif
visuel sensible sur scène mais que
finalement l'histoire qui se construit
elle se construit dans l'intimité du
spectateur et c'est cette histoire là
avec laquelle il repart et après ceux
qui boîent on retrouve la marche de
notre émission avec Catherine c'est tout
droit allez une date d'agenda aussi à
retenir à Noé une soirée spéciale
Arménie ce vendredi soir à la Maison de
la poésie de guyancour une première
partie consacrée à des champs d'Arménie
des poésies antiques et populaires un
spectacle proposé par Marianne horicost
et puis une deuxième partie éévane en
solo des poèmes de mariné pétrosscian
tarif à partir de 5 € pour les deux
spectacles
les vacances de pâqu approche on va
terminer justement ce magazine avec des
idées pour occuper vos enfants pendant
ces fameuses vacances on va démarrer par
magnichel lesamoau au domaine de Port
Royal des champs un atelier de poterie
est proposé pour s'initier aux
différentes techniques de colombin
plaque estampage et émaillage afin de
créer évidemment des œuvres originales
et puis à la Maison de l'Environnement
toujours à Mani c'est plus inattendu des
ateliers coutures pour découvrir les
bases de la couture alors savoir faire
un ourlaet réparer un trou ou coudre un
bouton le le 18 avril à part pour les 14
ans et le 23 avril pour les enfants à
partir de 8 ans et en cours maintenant à
la médiathèque des SEP Mar un atelier
duo peinture pour exercer ses talents
d'artiste en duo avec son enfant en
compagnie de Thomas chivalier artiste
contemporain en résidence et au prisme
toujours à a encour un atelier danse
pour partager cette fois un moment
intergénérationnel entre parents et
grands-parents ce sera notamment le
samedi 18 avril
trappe la ferme pédagogique de l'île des
loisirs vous propose des ateliers nature
pour apprendre à traire les chèvres ou à
fabriquer du fromage notamment les
dimanches 19 et 26 avril attrape
toujours c'est aussi assez original à la
Maison des Parents euh reconstitution
d'un procès avec la participation du
juge rosenvec ancien président pour
enfants de bobini c'est un atelier qui a
lieu du 20 au 24 avril à partir de 10
ans aguille en cour maintenant l'espace
numérique public Auguste Renoir propose
des stages de création musical pendant
toute la semaine prochaine des stages
aussi de création graphique également la
semaine prochaine du 20 au 22 avril et
puis des stages de création de jeux
vidéo pour apprendre évidemment à créer
son propre jeu vidéo ça ça va plaire
c'est sûr c'est du 27 au 29 avril tous
ces ateliers sont gratuit à Montini au
musée de la ville à l'atelier c'est du
propre pour confectionner par exemple
son gel douche à partir de produits
naturels et devenir écooresponsable ce
sera notamment le 22 avril et puis à
l'atelier cosmétique pour fabriquer des
produits cosmétiques bio et des
nettoyants écologiques ce sera le
lendemain le 23 avril et enfin on
termine par voisin le Bretonneux au
centre Alfred de Vigny et des ateliers
petit déj philo pour apprendre à mettre
ses idées en forme le mercredi 22 avril
pour les 5 10 ans et puis le centalf de
Ven qui propose aussi un stage d'atelier
poterie et dessin toute la semaine
prochaine du lundi au vendredi pour les
6 12 ans voilà quelques idées pour
occuper vos enfants pendant les vacances
c'est la fin de cette émission merci de
nous avoir suivi rendez-vous mercredi
prochain à la même heure d'ici là gardez
l'esprit ouvert et curieux bonne
soirée